I'm not I've got a little
hold where morality came
I really have a little bit of an of them
maybe it's of my own personal problem
but I hear a lot of judgment and
everything which is being said here I
hear a lot of we are sitting here doing
something really incredibly important
and great and high and necessary and
everybody else outside should come and
see how incredibly important it is they
don't know yet that they will know how
incredibly important is once they've
been exposed to this incredible thing
now obviously from a personal point of
you agree with you i am a musician i
think it is great but sorry bah and
mendelssohn and mozart who is what I do
every day have been dead for 200 years
now there are people outside in the
street who have other content that is
not less valid than what we do in this
hole so what I would say so what so then
a person employ l0n is a second I am the
first one to think since this is my life
that an orchestra is incredible as the
or creature that plays in this hole in a
building which has so much tradition and
history is incredibly important but it's
a part of what we have to do we cannot
lose contact with what's happening now
and with what why am I not me meme and
me a person of my age what has Mozart
got to do with me what has Shakespeare
got to do with me it's our role as
interpreters to find a bridge between
these works and these people but it's
also role to create things that happen
nowadays because if we go on telling
people in the street for the next 200
billion years that there's too stupid to
understand our great culture they won't
find it more interesting now
the point is we have we have to have
first of all not say it but feel deep
respect for other cultures other kinds
of interests of people that are not
interested in art that are not
interested in what we consider important
art but have true respect for what
interests them if we want them to have
respect for what interests us because I
think essentially art and what we try to
do here and I think that's what he said
because what I've been doing my whole
life is try to make music for people who
have never seen music before it's all
about an exchange it's about
communication I try to say something to
my audience I want to hear so I'm trying
to have an exchange with my audience if
somebody does it through music or
theater or through playing football or
through the reciting Chinese poetry I
don't care we have challenge we have to
get into a discussion we have to get
into a into a some sort of a platform
where we reached one another now one
last thing um what you said I completely
agree with it and it's it's that's what
I've been trying to do a lot as well and
and partially fail partially not I don't
know but it's very easy to convince
anybody in the street who has never been
to a concert before to go to a concert
once if you're a little bit charismatic
and you have three good excuses you will
find a way after 15 minutes to make them
try it out a completely different story
starts where it's about making there
come a second time you will not convince
anybody if they have been to an
experience which did not move them they
will not come even if you tell them 300
times that it was really important we
are always approaching this by expanding
oh it's about education and it's about
teaching and it's but explaining we
don't have to understand music music is
not there to be understood art is not
there to be industry I don't have to
look at a painting and understand
anything to know it's beautiful or refer
you to move me it either does or it
doesn't if music doesn't move you you
won't come back to a concert you
shouldn't I don't go to many concerts
because they just don't move me now why
do I have to go to a kid who is 10 say
I'm going to teach you for the next two
thousand years and
you will know enough to understand why
move music is good now we should just
make sure the problem starts with us
musicians or us artists we have to offer
something that is has substance that
will move our audience then it will come
we don't have to educate them in that
way will educate them to showing them
that real experience is possible that's
my opinion on grip on a subject listen
and let you know let me turn this an
alga to the floor your EA to to the
final general question and then we turn
to the audience and of course that if
you consider this a situation in which
arts and culture are much less important
and probably 100 years ago and before we
go to the world of politics or
technology or commercial life or
whatever what happens in the world of
course what happened in the world of art
that much less people are interested to
participate in all of this um yo D what
are your no I agree totally with what
you say but I think one of the problems
we have as you have said before we do
have the thing to specialize we have do
a program in in festival such luck with
the run on base with the great success
with people from Serbia Bosnia Turk I
Armenia our sig owners and I think we
have to open the music to every culture
and it's not only the music which
compose with great names which is
important because many of the courses
they have music like this so far the
people like your menu lighter serving
like this is pretty authentic music from
the life of the persons because this
music has helped had still today people
to survive and I think this is the
important when you say this its
touchable when you listen a Bosnian
singer singing ultimately
you feel these people is fighting for
his life for having the shots to be
alive you know and I think we have to
bring the music to this level of
authenticity one of the things that
makes the classical music bang it's
because we are Ottomans yeah we're uh
tonight we are not anymore trying to
swim but to use the music as a something
which is essential for life and I think
it's the shot is to open for really
music play by musicians they fight from
the life and for from the music but you
see this is in a way exactly result of
that you train people to specialize they
become at the end the people are the
people from from the Vulcans are not
this place well exactly that's why I
actually agree with you but I think what
happened in the classical world is that
we we completely we stopped encouraging
people to be personal and to be sincere
we encourage them to fit a certain rules
if they want to fit in certain boxes and
I completely agree with you if my music
does not represent my story and I don't
say my story when I play the audience
will feel it and they will not be moved
by it just by me executing notes
correctly it doesn't interest anybody I
completely agree with you and we must
make sure exactly as you said that we
don't maybe subconsciously have this
little bit of arrogance that we think
our music is better than other music
because there is no better music than
other music every culture of every every
art of every or every ritual of every
culture is as legitimate as important
and I think completely agree what you
say but I say still we we need musicians
they can play moza they can play surely
also because this also music from our
time okay and we need to use also have
you I must agree to you know what can I
do because because you are right but
maybe it's interesting to look at two
different layers the first one is that
um of course you need kind of know what
you are doing so the reason how to teach
children is with good teachers and
discounts for all walks of life it's
cause for music or folk art or whatever
if you know why this
come picture is moving you you can also
talk to somebody else about it if you
really know it so the first thing is
well all forms of music are forms of the
human animals singing to itself why
should one be more better than the other
of course you can say one is better done
than the other and then I would always
put emphasis on that one you can also
say one is better convey than the other
but what lies deeper is it's not only
about you feel your story when your sing
the song man yeah that's that only
brings you that's quite a limited
perspective because empathy enables us
to feel and to understand that we could
be the other in that situation like how
could you be moved by a picture if you
never sat on a horse by example and
there's somebody sitting on a horse you
know or how could you be moved by my
cigar if you never been through it and
also no nobody who has you know you you
know all this because you can feel for
the other and this is an access to all
things produce culturally into a
capacity of understanding them you do
not have to like them like there's
ghastly music out there please you know
but but you could understand that and
this broader understanding of something
with the human animal doesn't is capable
often would happen so here my thing for
me is the key to something like
education or two to find a 2000 year old
book incredibly interesting and fresh or
or two you know understand a music which
is not your own culture therefore
everything is valuable but you know if
it's nicely conducted but the question
is why is this big statement much less
evidence for so many people and what is
the responsibility why is it that the
world of arts and culture which has been
subsidized for many years why is it that
we you know world of culture world of
art or whatever have not been able to
convince a ruling class political
parties and especially you know an
audience that what we are doing is co
very very important what well where is
it that what is it that we did wrong
what I think I was thinking about what
you said this is a temple of music is it
cold like that the temple of music can I
say that a table without we hope a trash
holes temples of banana for music yeah
it's a terror love music but there is
not all music in this temple and that's
I think one of the mistakes we make
because if my son is studying
composition at the conservatory in
Amsterdam is very interested in jazz and
he is also very interested in rep and we
as an audience I think what I know now
because he is interested in that but a
very nice thing about rappers that I
live in a village like Rome or small
Phyllis like Gomes whatever I write bad
illness that they come from death and I
stay there and I want to tell about a
village how beautiful it is so my move
is not coming into the center my move is
there i want to show you i want to show
you how beautiful identity I i I've got
an important identity I've got that's
the sort of music but we I think me too
we have moved it out instead of looking
ignore it instead of looking how
beautiful it is because in Germany let's
say we have in my theater we have a big
big big music program but the Germans to
give an example count on a faith three
field a three field
the let's say the red people count like
that 8 a 3 feet which is completely
different and that we've lost that
feeling
you